[Music]
must be that time again another exciting
episode of Kos now today I want to bring
you something special
this is XM studios Prince named one now
he's the king of Atlantis now but you
know it was the prince at first right so
it's the huge statue over there
that's a monstrosity that's a fantastic
statute it is the heaviest base that I
have a huge statue it's a door mama
basically to be honest with you because
there's two dueling pieces and if you
look at it and when I'm saying dueling
pieces I mean they're like fighting for
your visual the love of your eyes
they're fighting for because the statue
himself Prince Namor himself is
beautifully detailed wonderfully
sculptured it's 1/6 scale it is insane
with the level of detail you see the
scales on a side of his soup he's in his
comic suit it's wonderfully done his
Trident is beautiful impeccably done
very heavy statute then when you get to
the giant octopus
I words can't describe the level of
detail that has gone into the texture of
this octopus and the water the ocean
that is raging against the octopus the
base is a three-part base right with the
tentacles that actually go on top of the
base as you can see from the pitches on
the side this is with great pleasure
that I bring you this character because
this is Marvel's only begotten son
this is Marvel's first hero and he's the
first in many rights you know he's the
first mutant he's the first hero he's
the first antihero rule of the sea
Prince Namor he's also one of the most
notorious villains so you have him
playing all three sides hero anti hero
and villain all the way live he's also
the first hero or character in the in
the Marvel Universe to have been on
every last major team the Avengers the
defenders
the loominatee the Fantastic Four he is
by far the most important character he's
even been on the x-men and a couple of
times he was in the Alpha Flight comic
books Neymar
let me give you a brief synopsis of the
character right first I know a lot of
you guys it's like yeah but Aquaman came
first he's biting off Aquaman a little
known fact named was debuted in 1939
Aquaman came in 1941 sorry bro yeah boy
Aquaman later oh you like but Aquaman
could talk to fish name or does that
ready name more stronger faster here's
these one of these strongest characters
at plus the hundred tons on land and
when he's under the sea
his strength doubles he's faster
stronger now the longer he's out of the
water the the weaker he becomes I think
his his base level will probably be 50
tons if he's at maximum dehydration but
and also he has little wings on his feet
check out his feet guys he has little
wings on his feet Namor is the son of a
sea captain who fell in love with an
Atlantean princess and she sired a child
which isn't anymore and he was born a
mutant the first mutant in Marvel's
history now not the first mutant overall
in the MCU let me be clear
they made it known that the first mutant
in the Marvel history his apocalypse
would get to that statue one of these
days but right now many more has his
shot so when he went back to the ocean
to find out his roots he found out that
he was from of Atlantean descent and so
his history begins
he is mainly fought alongside and
against the Fantastic Four he is also in
countless books with Doctor Doom super
Marvel team-up I believe it's called so
you know he's in there I might have
another little something that'll show
you those books to give you that uh
access to that but Namor is one of the
missing links in the MCU now I thought
when it casts Jason Momoa for Aquaman
they cast wrong I thought he was the
perfect name or I thought actually Jason
Momoa will look fantastic
he's a right size right build for Prince
Namor learn some books his savage
Submariner
this man has ran havoc throughout the
Marvel Universe
he doesn't age in the sense of normal
beings Namor is over a hundred years old
and but he still looks like a man in his
prime alright it looks like he's like
20-something years old and boy can he
fight
he's a tactician he's a general he's a
king he's a warrior
that shout emperess rex do you guys
remember the cartoon they used to come
oh I think it was on Saturdays
right after hanna-barbera give you a
little snippet of it right there
fantastic cartoon I showed my son this
car to another dick he looked at me like
you used to watch that daddy yes daddy
used to watch that well without further
ado I want you guys to you know I want
you to stick around because I can't wait
for you to get the visual on this and
we'll give you a lot of detail pitches
give you a lot of video now this one is
too large for any base that I have like
I have bases even the manual ones even
the motorized one base is too big it
doesn't sit on it properly remember I
told you it's put together by three
parts so I would like for you guys to
like follow and subscribe don't forget
to hit that Bell icon so anytime Kos
comes up you guys can get to new stuff
every Wednesday also tune in to combat
talk with the king it's with this guy
over here when I talk about all the
combat that goes on and these fighting
streets also tune in to the last word
with Laurel kognito and lordy pontus to
get all the ludus shooter news also
follow up with us at ILP on Sundays and
1 p.m.
standard Eastern Time hey we also
at Lourdes a gaming dotnet we can get
all the new information on everything
that's happening in these gaming streets
and also with these statues man I'm
having such a ball and it's due to you
guys that I keep pushing forward
now keep bringing you great content and
I'm just having a ball bringing you my
childhood so without further ado I give
you guys Princeton anymore should we say
King Submariner haha yeah I think that
sounds a whole lot better see you next
week guys when I bring you another epic
statue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]